this morning we are hearing more from
the parents of one of the two women
living with singer R Kelly 21 year old
Ezreal Clary and 23 year old Joycelyn
savage told us that they love the 50 52
year old singer was pleaded not guilty
to charges of abusing four women they
say there is nothing inappropriate about
their relationship while their parents
of course feel very differently they say
that Kelly has brainwashed their
daughters and is keeping the women
against their will they have been trying
desperately to reconnect with their
daughters for quite some time
deutschland savage called her parents
shortly after our interview with Kelly
aired on Wednesday to let them know that
she is okay we spoke with Timothy and
John Jill and savage late last night and
their attorney about that call and why
they believe it's still not too late to
reconnect with their daughter tell us
about that conversation we all heard it
but from your point of view tell us
about that conversation I call them
prison calls because I can tell that
someone is listening to the calls and
she called with a one with a script I'm
up Tony I'm happy where I touch it means
I'm happy where I am and then her two
younger sister came in and say hi
joseline Hey
it's jewelry she paused like 10 seconds
we're like she seemed to have a reaction
to Joey's voice to her younger sisters
they supposed to they can have a
connection with the younger kids and
when she talked to George he just for a
second
that was Josslyn and then she she hung
up the telephone right she said she had
to go like she was in jail or somewhere
John Dylan and Timothy savage say it's
been nearly two and a half years since
they last saw their daughter Joycelyn in
person they say Joycelyn enjoyed singing
growing up and they believed r.kelly
could help their daughter with her
professional career
Kelly was acquitted of child pornography
charges in 2008 so you felt comfortable
because he had been acquitted of the
charges not only he being acquitted of
charges but I felt comfortable because I
I separate at the time I wish I didn't
but I separated the are this from the
man the savages say Joycelyn first met r
kelly at one of his shows in 2015
kelly claims Joycelyn father brought her
to the concert I didn't go looking for a
Jocelyn Savage I was doing my show he
brought her and asked a friend of mine
to put her on the stage with our Kelly
never have that ever happened so you
didn't bring her to the show no I did
not have you met our Kelly I've never
met mr. Kelly you have never met our
Kelly never in my entire life met mr.
Kelly I've only talked to him one time
on the phone and at one time you know
what he told me he said you gonna have
to wait to see your daughter trust the
process
how can you tell another father to trust
the process but you rapping and raging
on TV that you want to see your kids but
you won't allow me to see my own
daughter how do you think that makes me
feel as a father Joycelyn and Ezreal
Clary have been living with Kelly at his
home in Chicago they say their parents
have had a different agenda my parents
definitely started this whole situation
which situation what
what's going on you know basically lying
and trying to give money and bringing
out all these different lies and stuff
you know my parents they put out
especially my dad he's the whole master
of this whole situation did either of
you try to get money from our Kelly no
no you never got money from him
and you never tried to get money from
him is that what you're saying no no
only business dealing were potentially
four relate to my daughter so why is
your daughter saying that this is all
about money that you all are only out
for the money what is she what is she
talking about I have no clue what my
daughter is she's brainwashed do you
believe your relationship with your
daughter can be repaired yes because we
love her we get it properly because
right now it's unclear what's going to
happen to our Kelly yes as we sit here
today he's he's in jail but there you
know it's believed that he will be out
of jail very soon a father's love for
his daughter will never change a man
loving his daughter can change but a
father love will never change for his
daughter what do you all have to say to
our Kelly really really he need to rot
in jail
I'm sorry but that's just the way I feel
I'm sorry that he needs help but this
man has done so many women wrong he
needs to rot in that Jail seal period
well joseline savage and ezreal Clarice
say they have they have never wanted a
singing career as real Clarice family
also denies asking for receiving money
from our Kelly Kelly as you know
consistently denied sexually abusing
women and controlling their lives and
Jericka just sent this to me she said
she didn't have time to put it in her
script but that Dominique the the girl
who did get away said that the girls
used to rehearse what to say in videos
what to tell their families Wow
Dominique misses these two young girls
because she was also with them but our
Kelly used to have them according to
Dominique used to have them rehearse
what to say they were talking to their
families yes so call which is what the
mother said
felt that they were talking things we
could hear that slight hiccup and
Joycelyn heard her sister giorious voice
right yeah yeah there was definitely a
pause a reminder you can watch our
interview with our Kelly and a primetime
special it airs tonight at 8:00 7:00
central right here on CBS